As we grow up and get older, our bodies begin
to change.
Sometimes, those changes can be a bit uncomfortable,
or even bizarre.
We feel strange pains in new places, we grow
seemingly a foot in height overnight, hair
sprouts up in new places, and falls out of
other places.
Whether it's puberty or just the aging process,
it seems like the human body never runs out
of ways to surprise us!
But those surprises are completely normal,
and to be expected as part of being alive.
Unless you’re one particular young man whose
body changed overnight into something unrecognizable,
and entirely anomalous.
That’s where a very special individual we’ll
be calling Matt Terra comes in.
Matt was an ordinary 24-year-old man, with
nothing particularly interesting about him.
Sure, he was a nice guy, he was smart, he
was great at chess and video games and had
an impressive memory for science trivia, but
there was nothing unusual about him.
Every day he would get up, go to work at a
board game and comic book store, chat with
his coworkers and make a few sales, head home,
make dinner, relax, and go to bed ready to
do it all again the next day.
It wasn’t a glamorous life, or that exciting,
but it was a pleasant life, and he was happy
to live it.
One night, Matt was having a difficult time
sleeping.
He was tossing and turning, waking up every
few minutes to a dull aching feeling in his
stomach.
He didn’t feel feverish or sick, and the
pain wasn’t sharp or indicative of an emergency,
so he shrugged it off as indigestion and tried
to get back to sleep.
We’ve all been there, right?
Eventually, he nodded off all the way.
He woke the next morning, blurry-eyed and
exhausted from the rough night, but feeling
otherwise fine.
He climbed out of bed, stretched, and headed
into the bathroom to brush his teeth.
There, in the mirror, he saw something that
made him think he might still be dreaming.
He pinched himself, and found that he was
indeed awake.
While he was sleeping, somehow his body had
changed into something completely impossible.
Where his stomach had once been, there was
a blue, green, and brown orb that reminded
him of a photograph he had once seen: a picture
of the Earth, taken from aboard the International
Space Station.
After calling into work and explaining, in
a stammering voice, that he would not be coming
in that day, Matt did the only thing he could
think of: he went to the hospital.
Of course, the doctors had no idea what to
do with him.
It wasn’t like they could just take out
his appendix or give him an antibiotic, none
of them had ever seen anything like this before.
Fortunately for him, one doctor knew a lot
more than he was letting on.
Matt wouldn’t be the first human to develop
bizarre anomalous traits and then stagger
into a nearby hospital for treatment.
That’s why the SCP Foundation has agents
embedded in major hospitals all across the
world - And one such doctor was the man treating
Matt.
On the downside, he wouldn’t be enjoying
his freedom much longer.
On the upside, it’d cost a hell of a lot
less than a regular, uninsured hospital visit.
So, the field agent called up his superiors,
wiped Matt’s record from the hospital, and
soon after, a group of Foundation agents came
to collect the confused, unfortunate host
of what would soon be known as SCP-007.
SCP-007 is found within an abdominal cavity
on the body of Matt - also referred to as
the Subject - just below his rib cage where
his stomach would be.
Most of his abdomen is completely missing,
including the muscles, skin, and organs that
should ordinarily be necessary for his survival.
However, he does not appear to experience
any pain or even discomfort from his condition.
SCP-007 itself is a spherical planet, composed
of soil and water, none of which actually
touches any part of his body.
The planet resembles a miniature duplicate
of Earth, about 60 centimeters in diameter,
with its own weather patterns and gravitational
pull, neither of which appear to have any
effect on the Subject, nor do they seem to
be affected by his movements or behavior.
There are also a variety of tiny organisms
dwelling on the planet’s surface that cannot
be seen with the naked eye.
Though it greatly resembles Earth, there are
some notable differences.
Obviously, instead of floating in space and
revolving around the Sun, this planet does
not appear to have an orbit.
It is uncertain where the organisms on the
planet get their light from, though it does
not seem to be our Sun, since the organisms
have not shown any negative effects from the
lack of sunlight (and presence of artificial
light) in the Foundation Site.
There are continents visible on the planet’s
surface, surrounded by its sea, but they do
not resemble a continental alignment that
can be traced to any point in our Earth’s
history.
As for the life on the small planet - the
organisms navigating the surface of the world
inside Matt’s abdomen - there are dozens
of identifiable species that bear a passing
resemblance to creatures on Earth.
There are blue cow-like livestock, species
of birds that appear to have scales, red and
orange trees, and other plant life, and two
intelligent species that are notably and significantly
humanoid in appearance and behavior.
Observation of these intelligent species via
microscope and digital imaging has revealed
that they operate in societies and are consistently
developing and improving their technology.
Though their technology was incredibly rudimentary
when Matt was first brought into containment,
resembling early Nomadic human civilizations,
it has progressed to the level of 15th-Century
humanity.
The Research Team assigned to SCP-007 has
noticed the recent introduction of a version
of the printing press, used to produce what
appear to be pamphlets and even entire books.
The language these books are printed in is
unrecognizable, and so the contents of these
materials are currently unknown, but the citizens
of the planet clearly have a grasp of the
written word, and both the technology and
the desire to share it amongst themselves.
They have also developed an agricultural system.
Their farms have progressed to the point of
using new inventions such as windmills, used
to mill grain, wheelbarrows used to transport
crops and other supplies, and the practice
of crop rotation.
Unfortunately, with these positive developments
comes the ability to escalate conflicts and
wage wars.
They look to have created parachutes, gunpowder,
and other explosives, and their own versions
of the muzzle-loaded rifle.
However, in spite of the ugliness of battle,
there is beauty too.
The people of the planet have created new
ways to express themselves, with what can
only be described as new instruments, closely
resembling the piano, the mandolin, and the
bagpipes.
As exciting, and even moving, as it can be
to watch these tiny beings grow and change,
building their own miniature society, it is
also a bit troubling.
As these people continue to progress at such
a fast rate, it stands to reason that they
will eventually catch up to us, or even surpass
us, in terms of technology.
The Research Team has not yet made any attempts
to communicate with the inhabitants of the
abdominal planet, concerned about influencing
the developments of its societies in any way
or compromising their ability to observe them
without interfering, but they may not be able
to keep this up for much longer.
What will happen if these tiny beings continue
to follow in our footsteps, and create their
very own space programs?
If they leave their planet’s atmosphere,
they will discover the truth: that their world
is buried in the abdomen of what is, to them,
a giant man.
That reality would be enough to shatter the
sanity of many of us, and it would likely
cause chaos on their world.
There has been a great deal of debate amongst
the Research Team about what to do if this
should happen.
Some insist that the team should continue
to passively observe until the issue comes
up, while others believe that they should
attempt to make contact with the inhabitants
of the planet, in order to soften the eventual
blow to their perceptions when they attempt
space exploration.
Currently, the debate rages on, as the Research
Team keeps an eye on the progression of the
little civilizations.
Hopefully, if they do eventually make contact,
they will find a way to make it clear that
we come in peace.
So, who is Matt Terra, the Subject?
He is a highly intelligent young man, with
a shockingly casual attitude toward his body’s
anomalous properties.
When asked about the planet, he simply says,
“I just woke up one day, and there it was.
I don’t have any idea how it got there.”
Testing revealed that he is genetically human,
and there is nothing unusual or even notable
about the rest of his body.
He provided his name willingly upon arriving
at the SCP Foundation, but no one of his name
and age has ever lived in his hometown area
according to public records.
To verify his identity, he was able to produce
a Social Security card and a driver’s license,
which did not appear to be forged or altered
in any way.
However, when the numbers were run through
the system, there was no match.
Officially, the man does not exist.
It is not entirely certain where he came from,
or why there is no record of him, but one
researcher posited that he somehow crossed
over from a parallel dimension, or that the
presence of his abdominal planet added a kind
of cognitohazardous effect to him that erased
all perception of him from any records.
Whatever the case may be, wherever he came
from, he is here now.
Because he has not yet attempted escape, or
even shown a desire to leave the Foundation
site, there are no strict containment procedures
in place.
The only active containment procedures for
SCP-007 are for the Subject’s safety and
security.
He lives in a sealed room filled with furniture
and other items, which are granted upon request
as long as they do not pose a security risk.
The Subject’s room includes an easy chair,
a bed, a bean bag chair, a television with
access to several movie and television streaming
services, a number of video game consoles,
an espresso machine, a microwave, a refrigerator,
an exercise bike, and a bookshelf filled with
books and graphic novels.
Though he does not appear to require food
or water in order to survive, he enjoys consuming
both food and drinks, and is especially fond
of coffee, sodas, grape juice, sour cream
and onion potato chips, mangoes, and the occasional
treat of Chinese takeout, an opinion which
he shares with the eccentric Dr. Clef.
The head researcher assigned to SCP-007, Dr.
Cho, has a weekly game of chess with Matt,
during which he evaluates the Subject’s
mental health and general emotional well-being.
Over the course of these games, the two have
developed a friendly relationship, with each
man winning about half of the time.
Matt asks about Dr. Cho’s family, and in
return Dr. Cho checks in about his containment
situation, seeing if there is anything the
Foundation can provide to make his time with
them more comfortable.
Most recently, Matt requested a computer with
an internet connection, mainly so that he
could play his video games in online co-op
mode, but this request was denied out of a
concern that it would compromise Foundation
security.
Sympathetic to his desire for company, Dr.
Cho has begun to allow the Subject to have
visits with SCP-507, who will stop by his
containment facility during his inactive periods
for a movie night or some video games.
Matt has described 507 as his “best friend
aside from Dr. Cho.”
In spite of the intricate world inexplicably
floating in his body, the Subject leads a
relatively simple life.
He does not seem to be restless, or resentful
at all.
In fact, he seems largely content.
Though his future is uncertain, and he is
living through a completely unprecedented
anomalous experience, he is probably one of
the happiest anomalies contained at the SCP
Foundation, and definitely one of the most
at peace with his anomalous status.
Whatever happens next for him, he will probably
be ready for it with a smile, and there’s
something we can all learn from that.
Now go check out “SCP-662 - Butler's Hand
Bell” and “SCP-507 - Reluctant Dimension
Hopper” for more unusual, but harmless,
humanoid SCPs!